right here in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions dan is with us hey Dan how are
you man I'm doing better than I deserve
how about you I've heard that before I
think you have just the same sir
so what city are you from Tallahassee
very cool very cool and you are like a
caller and are like a visitor in the
other hour a team member of a company
yes that has taught our smart dollar
product which is where employees go
through and learn how to handle money
yes over the last nine months and that's
caused you to pay off some debt how much
debt have you paid off twelve thousand
nine hundred dollars I love it very cool
and you did that over nine months yep
household income around 50 okay very
cool what kind of debt was the thirteen
thousand one hundred percent credit card
ah very good very cool so how have you
had that credit card
Oh lordie several years yeah mm-hmm some
of them I see people my age your age
that have had credit cards longer than
they've had their kids that wasn't a
problem yeah I just started to slip back
into bad habits oh that's real good for
quite a few years yeah it's easy it's
subtle in it oh yes yeah just like a
drunkard with a drink I can handle just
one drink
yeah and for you look up you're falling
off the wagon and it's pulling away yeah
exactly
oh so you nine months ago your employer
the company name is municipal code
corporation Unicode Unicode and your
leader decided to take the team through
smart dollar and teach them how to
handle money yes our very proactive
president Eric grant and he's been all
behind this a hundred percent really
pushing it and it's gonna be great for
everybody in the company that does it
well he's been cheerleading there's no
question about it oh yes he is that kind
of a guy so but god it's good leadership
because you know the companies are
finding that when their team is under
control with money they make better team
members absolutely yeah happier
employees gonna do a better job yeah
very cool very cool so what happened to
you during this nine months that enabled
you to pay off $13,000 in debt
last spring when I turned the grand old
age of around 56 it occurred to me what
happened to my parents about 30 years
ago they hit rock bottom
they had to start over in their late 50s
who and they did it they had to move
from South Carolina's Lowcountry up to
Atlanta okay
leaning on family and friends okay 13
years later they had paid off a house
nothing had some retirement money saved
up so anybody out there and listen in
the land you're facing a tough time in
your 40s late 50s and starting to have
him start over you can it's amazing what
happens when you get on the stick in it
in it though and fortunately I was in
nowhere near the dire straits my family
was 30 years ago
yeah and I didn't want to get there and
I was having bad habits with credit
cards again I was not in dire straits
but uh it was a bad habit mmm rolling
over balance is not paying them all so
yeah paying off 13,000 is impressive but
you know what feels if I'm in your shoes
I'm gonna put words in your mouth you
correct me okay but if I'm in your shoes
what feels even better is just the fact
hey I took control of this and I own it
now it doesn't own me exactly and I'm
paying three or four or less bills a
month yeah it's awfully nice yeah I knew
that gives you a lot more room in the
budget to do some other things and
invest for retirement and none to that
all of that so very cool so what would
you tell people the secret to paying off
$13,000 in nine months is getting fed up
with yourself and just it's discipline
take care of it if you're fortunate
enough to have a company that's often
offering this service go through watch
the videos take it to heart very cool
and you will be encouraged listening to
other people well thank you Dan I
appreciate that very good stuff it is
encouraging there people are be
encouraged listening to you right now
this is very cool
well done all right Dan from Tallahassee
Florida $13,000 paid off in nine months
making fifty thousand a year counted
down
let's hear a debt free scream I'm debt
free yes
love it love it love it well done well
done sir
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim